in light of the anti-vaccine problem
that we have in the united states which
may well prevent us from really getting
past this pandemic there are now more
and more people calling for
mandatory
that's government-mandated vaccination
now i want to be really clear
there is a huge difference between
required to do something and straight up
compelled vaccination in other words
we've had for a long time vaccines that
are required if you want
to go to a certain college to send your
kid to a certain school to work in
certain places that wouldn't be new
what people are now actually talking
about more seriously some people it's
not predominant
is the idea of government actually
mandating that people must be vaccinated
period you have to just get the vaccine
a government-mandated vaccine there's an
op-ed in the washington post by max boot
who some people hate
called stop pleading with anti-vaxxers
and start mandating vaccinations now
there are really two parts here first of
all is the question of would a mandatory
vaccine be legal now as a federal
government mandate
there does not appear to be precedent
for that that you know it sometimes when
we talk about whether something would be
legal
the the language should not be
it doesn't seem like it would be legal
but rather
we're not able to find precedent that
that would be legal at the state level
the answer appears to be that yes state
government in many states could mandate
vaccination you look at jacobson v
massachusetts from 1905
that was a supreme court case
in which the court upheld
the authority of states to enforce
compulsory vaccination laws
the court at the time articulated the
view that individual liberty is not
absolute and is subject to the police
power of the state quote massachusetts
was one of only 11 states that had
compulsory vaccination laws
massachusetts law empowered the board of
health of individual cities and towns to
enforce mandatory free vaccinations for
adults over age 21 if the municipality
determined it was necessary for the
public health or safety of the community
if you refused you had to pay a five
dollar fine in 1902 faced with the
outbreak of smallpox the board of health
of the city of cambridge adopted a
regulation ordering the vaccination or
re-vaccination of inhabitants basically
pointing out that uh this is part of
preserving liberty when there is a
public health imperative so
legally it's certainly conceivable that
states which wanted to make the covet
vaccine mandatory could do it then you
would get into questions like does it
apply
to people who are legally residents of
the state what if you're traveling
through what if you're temporarily
working in a particular state there's a
ton of complexity that's not really the
issue for me
i am not actively for
mandatory vaccination i'm for informing
people
and encouraging vaccination in other
ways
but it would be political suicide to try
to make the covet vaccine mandatory many
of the people who don't want to get
vaccinated really don't want to get
vaccinated and i believe it would be
unmitigated political disaster for
anyone who tries to push mandatory
vaccination now one other thing in terms
of the current supreme court
my guess is
that the current court
would only go with the precedent of
states being able to mandate vaccination
if and when these vaccines are fully
approved by the fda my instinct is that
if a state tried to do this and there
was a lawsuit and an appeal and an
appeal and eventually got to the supreme
court that the supreme court is not
going to uphold the precedent when it
comes to an emergency use authorization
i i just don't imagine that
one idea i had which i tweeted about was
this is now other ways to get people
vaccinated i tweeted if a rumor started
that liberals want to keep the vaccine
away from conservatives so that they die
would it make them get vaccinated to own
the libs this is really childish reverse
psychology but at the same time
it's this type of thing that seems far
more plausible and maybe even more
effective than a government mandated
vaccination i would be curious to hear
from you we've been talking about
this week what if the the vaccines were
marketed
as the trump vaccine as trump juice
uh as a freedom vaccine or whatever the
case may be
would that maybe get some of these
people to go out and get vaccinated when
it comes to mandatory vaccinations even
if you can find legal precedent for it i
don't think it's the way to go in
particular because the backlash and
people who figure out a way to avoid it
anyway and the potential uh politically
suicidal aspect of it it doesn't seem
like the way to go i want to hear from
you though you can find me on twitter at
deepakman and let me know your thoughts
and also
we are approaching the 16th anniversary
of the david pakman show and to
celebrate that we will be doing a
one-day membership special on monday
august 16th it's not this month i got an
email yesterday from someone saying
david sir congratulations on 16 years
i'm sorry i'm a few days late they were
actually a month early it is august 16th
technically the 17th
but 16th at midnight anyway you know how
these things go we will be doing a huge
email blast on the 16th telling you how
to take advantage of just an
unconscionable membership discount
be notified
by getting on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com